what is going on everybody and welcome
back to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren
Thompson and right now we are about to
dive head first into the true Multiverse
Saga of the MCU starting off phase five
with Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania
and our true introduction to our big bad
the Multiverse Saga King the Conqueror
yes we were sort of introduced to King
the Conqueror but we were introduced to
he who remains in Loki who is very
different something that a lot of people
may not realize about he who remains is
that he actually found a way to end the
war and as he says he isolated his
timeline after that and simply kept his
own sacred timeline this is very
different than what we're about to
experience with King the Conqueror you
see King the Conqueror is really a title
and a true conqueror doesn't just
isolate his own timeline and keep it
safe from all the other kings that's who
he who remains was but Kang is different
in the fact that he wants to conquer all
of the other timelines now this may seem
like common knowledge but the point that
I'm really trying to drive home here is
that he who remains was actually quite
good and we've recently got some new
information about Loki season 2 that
we're going to go over in this video
about what to expect from Kang in Loki
season 2 and Kang's variants the
multiversal war The Secret Wars is
coming Loki season 1 was phenomenal and
it was very important to the Multiverse
Saga it really introduced us to what
variants actually are and what they can
be they don't all have to look the same
they can look different they can also
look the same some could be good some
could be evil some could be a man some
could be a woman in a Multiverse of
infinite universes there are essentially
infinite amounts of variance as well in
what they could be and things are about
to go down in Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania but then really go down in
Loki season 2. according to Insider
Daniel rpk Loki season 2 is going to
feature several different King variants
and is going to have serious
ramifications for the MCU you see right
now we believe that there are two King
the conquerors stuck inside of the
quantum realm if you kind of ignore the
fact that the captions for the script of
the movie got leaked briefly Marvel
Studios really is doing a good job of
not telling us too much of what is going
to happen in quantumania but we do know
that at least two Kang variants are
going to be inside of the quantum realm
in Quantum Mania and one of those
variants most likely the one that is
speaking to Scott Lang in the trailer is
trying to overcome and overtake the
other variant and this is the main Kang
this is Kang the Conqueror who is going
to be the main villain of the King
Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars that's
very important to note because we are
about to experience a lot of different
Kang variants so Loki season 1 told us
about the multiversal war Miss minutes
told us about it a little bit and then
he who remains told us the true story it
was a war between all of the different
variants of King that is what is going
to happen in Loki season 2. and this is
where the TVA is going to be used in a
completely different way one came the
Conqueror possibly the main one will be
using the TVA not to seclude his
timeline and keep it sacred and safe but
we'll be using the TVA to conquer other
timelines and this is really what Loki
and Sylvie and of course Mobius are
going to have to deal with in Loki
season 2. the last thing that we heard
from Loki in the ending of season 1 is
that he's coming and he's terrifying but
then we saw that the TVA was actually
already changed we saw a statue of King
the Conqueror and Mobius had no idea who
Loki was Kang had already altered
everything but here's the deal Kang is
going to use the TVA to try and Conquer
other timelines but other variants of
Kang are going to be trying to conquer
the TVA each evil variant of Nathaniel
Richards who was the original name of
the first king the Conqueror wants to
conquer the other kings and who knows
some other kangs might have a TVA of
their own because remember the TV8 is
only used to monitor one timeline it's
most likely that other kings out there
have made a TVA of their own and it
looks like we might have a good idea of
what Loki Mobius and Sylvie will be
doing in Loki season 2 and a new
character which is going to be a variant
of Kang who is also going to be
introduced as well but first a big thank
you to factor for sponsoring this video
look this new year I've got goals you've
got goals and factor is here to help you
achieve each and every one of them save
time and have the energy you need to
tackle everything on your to-do list
with factors ready to eat meals
delivered straight to your door look
I've tried many different ready to go
meals delivered straight to my door and
all of them were kind of just okay but
truly factor is the first ready to eat
meal I've ever had where I thought it
was amazing I cannot get over how great
these taste and if you're trying to save
time this New Year's they help you skip
the grocery store and they're ready to
go in just two minutes they're always
fresh and never Frozen and the best part
is no matter what your lifestyle Factor
has meals to help you live your life to
the fullest with keto calorie smart
vegan plus veggie and Protein Plus meals
on the menu each week so if you're
trying to eat Smart this new year like
me factor is perfect for you seriously
each meal that I've had has been
absolutely delicious and I've never had
to worry about where I'm going to eat or
what I'm going to eat because Factor has
me covered so right now head to
factor75.com and use code Cosmic Wonder
6-0 to get 60 off your first Factor box
so according to a report from Insider
Daniel Richmond we are going to see a
very different variant of Kang and Loki
season 2 amongst other variants now one
specific variant that Daniel rpk
described is described as an inventor in
the past who wanted to buy specific
things in order to affect the future now
although this isn't much it actually
tells us some pretty important
information and let's start with who
this variant might be this might be
Victor timely now for clarification Kang
the conqueror's real name is Nathaniel
Daniel Richards like I mentioned before
and Victor timely still is Nathaniel
Richards he is simply going by another
name what happens is in the comics The
Avengers actually defeat King one of the
times and then Kang or Nathaniel travels
back in time to the year 1901 and he
travels back to this time to plan a
modern Conquest so he goes back to 1901
to Wisconsin and he poses himself as a
man named Victor timely he goes on to
establish a town that he names timely
super original he becomes the town mayor
and he grows the town and he sets up
many businesses many factories and he
does a lot of good for it he also
develops a lot of technology that leads
to the invention of the original Human
Torch Android being brought to life now
through generations he posed as Victor
timely and Victor timely's heirs so
basically he was Victor timely and then
Victor timely son and the grandson and
the great grandson so on and so forth
much like Kingo did in the eternals but
Victor timely most importantly also
created chronopolis and we believe that
the city that is in the quantum realm is
indeed chronopolis now it is important
to note that Daniel rpk did not know 100
if this variant is indeed going to be
Victor timely he did say he is not sure
so it's not confirmed to be Victor
timely but things are kind of connecting
here and another important thing that
this does tell us is that in Loki season
2 it seems like Loki and Mobius are
going to be going to the past and trying
to find earlier versions of Kang now we
know they're not going to the past to
try and correct it or to try and kill
him because as we learned in Avengers
end game changing your past does not
affect your future it will create a new
timeline and I'm pretty sure Mobius and
Loki aren't trying to create any more
timelines because that will create more
kangs but what I'm theorizing is
happening here is that Loki and Mobius
are probably trying to get a feel of
what Kang's technology really is how did
he develop it how does it work how does
he harness time travel and possibly they
might be thinking how could they get a
hold of the same technology so they can
use Kang's own technology against him
now based off of some set photos that
we've seen of Loki season 2 and the tiny
little teaser that Disney has shown us
so far we know that Loki and Mobius are
going to be going back through time a
lot from what we've seen and heard so
far and again since we know from
Avengers end game and really from Loki
season 1 as well that change in the past
won't correct the future we can assume
that they're mostly time traveling for
information or perhaps and this is my
other Theory they are searching for a
good version of Nathaniel Richards the
MCU does tend to change things
rightfully so because if everything was
exactly how it was in the comics we
would know what was going to happen so
Victor timely this variant of Kang could
end up being a good guy and they might
be seeking his help to defeat his evil
variants after all he who remains in the
Loki season finale did explain that not
all were peaceful meaning that some
indeed were peaceful and he did explain
that originally when these different
universes made contact with each other
it was really good and they shared
technology and helped each other grow
and they complimented each other and
basically it was very peaceful but then
some evil variants came and that changed
everything so since we're going to see
many different variants of Kang and Loki
season 2 I want to assume that some
might actually be good and perhaps the
reason Loki and Mobius are traveling
back through different points in time is
to possibly find some of these nice and
good variants but let us know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe stay up to date on the latest
MCU news for live updates you can follow
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof